Sunil Parekh from Zydus catalyst a
teaching advisor I have enjoyed quite a
few of the sessions that held today and
the panel discussions were far more
Frank and the fact that there was not
many much of government here actually
allowed a lot of private views to be
aired very very vocally and the kind of
frank discussions that have taken place
is representing the kind of discussions
that are likely to catapult us in the
future the session with the young global
leaders and global shapers was an
exceptionally good one which was so
different from the ones that we have
which involves very little of the kind
of structured thinking and much more of
what the young people really want to do
with their lives and how good they say
is the vision of a new India the very
inspiring